Hello! How many languages
can you speak? 1, 2, maybe 3?
Or you could impress us with even more languages
but guess what:
Google’s new machine
translation system can translate between more than
a thousand languages! We bet no one can do that.
In this video, we will basically summarize
the 57 pages of this paper for you,
to see what the researchers had to do to
collect data for more than 1,000 languages,
how they trained their machine translation
models and in which ways they surprised us!
So, grab a cup of coffee, because it
is time to discuss about multilingual
transformers in this AI Coffee Break!
But first, let’s thank Weights&Biases
for sponsoring today’s video!
Weights and Biases is an
MLOps platform, helping you
and your team improve the process of building
and maintaining Machine Learning models.
It helps with experiment tracking, saving
model configurations for easy reproduction,
hyperparameter search, and many
other things! It gets even better:
Weights & Biases lives where you work
- Stay focussed on training models in
whichever ML library you know and love - Weights
& Biases has callbacks or loggers for Keras,
PyTorch Lightning, Hugging Face,
YOLOv5, MMDetection and more.
Just pass 1 line of code to
turn on experiment tracking,
model checkpointing and data visualization
and get back to training your models.
For example, when using Hugging Face Transformers
just set report_to = 'wandb' in the
Trainer Arguments to turn on logging.
If you’re a Keras user just pass the
WandbCallback to the .fit method and
if you’re a PyTorch Lightning user then passing
the WandbLogger to the Trainer will turn on rich
logging of your experiment metrics and
system performance metrics for free!
Go to wandb.me/ai-coffee-break to
find out more about Weights&Biases!
Now back to the video. Today we are
talking about machine translation models,
like the ones behind Google Translate.
As you’ve maybe already
noticed with Google Translate,
while for some language pairs like English and
German, the translation quality is impressive,
for rarer language pairs, the
translation quality can be lower.
Although, we cannot really demonstrate this for
German-Romanian or other language pairs I speak,
since the algorithms are probably
based on transformer models and have
improved their performance quite a lot lately.
But the bad news is, that some languages
are not even covered by Google Translate.
One reason for this is that it is hard
to find enough training data for them.
And Google Translate is just an example, the
problem that some languages work better than
others, is well known for machine translation
systems, not just for Google Translate:
Languages for which you can find a lot
of text on the internet (so high-resource
languages) like English, German, French,
Spanish, have high machine translation quality,
because you know the motto of neural
networks: the more data, the better.
But there are lots and lots
of low-resource languages
for which you can find very little
or no data on the world wide web.
Just so you get an idea, there are more than
7000 languages spoken in the world today,
but machine translation systems have been built
for around 100 languages so far, for which the
data collection was easy and where there is
more economical incentive to cover a language.
As the paper points out, we cite
“Despite high speaker populations,
languages spoken in Africa, South and South-East
Asia and indigenous languages of the Americas
are relatively under-served. For example,
Google Translate supports Frisian, Maltese,
Icelandic, and Corsican, each with fewer than
1M L1 speakers, but not (up until this work)
Bhojpuri (~51M speakers), Oromo
(~24M speakers) [and so on]”.
So the authors refer to these languages
as long-tail languages, “since the data
scarcity requires the application
of machine learning techniques that
can generalize beyond the languages for
which ample training data is available.”
So, the idea of this paper is: if
we want to go far beyond hundreds
of languages to reach the order
of magnitude of the thousands,
the authors need to crawl a dataset that
captures the long tail too. Easy, right?
No, it turned out to be
much harder than I thought.
No wonder this paper is such a long one,
describing a lot of the problems that
can arise when trying to collect
data for low-resource languages.
But first, what kind of data are we
talking about? The training data of modern,
neural machine translation systems is a mix of
parallel and monolingual data. Parallel data
is key for machine translation because it means
that for each sentence in a language, we have
the same sentence in a different language.
Clearly, this data should be the most
valuable for learning to translate.
But imagine, that pairs of sentences in
different languages are not as cheap and
easy to get as monolingual text where
we have sentences just in one language.
Researchers (at Google, not me)
have parallel data for 112 languages
consisting of 25 billion sentence pairs.
To get to a thousand languages, the
parallel data strategy cannot scale
(at least not for now) and machine
translation systems that train on
any available parallel data, can also
train on additional monolingual data.
The crazy part is that through
back translation and self-training,
they learn to translate between languages
for which there is no parallel data!
But let’s not get ahead of us
now, our point here is, that
to extend machine translation
to a thousand languages,
the best bet of the authors is to collect
monolingual data of a thousand languages.
Then to train a model on the parallel
data they already have and also on all
monolingual sentences and bam: they can enable
machine translation for a thousand languages!
Then, great! Let’s gather some monolingual
data for more than a thousand languages.
It should be easy, right? Right?
No, it is not. Kreutzer and collaborators
(2022) show that data gathering strategies that
work for high-resource languages,
are gathering way too much noise for
low-resource languages and therefore
cannot be applied in the same way.
The problem here is, that to
gather data for a language,
one first needs to identify whether text from
the internet is written in that language.
To do this at internet-level, this
language identification should be fast,
so using a transformer model
is maybe not the best idea.
Even worse, after gathering the data, storing
it before filtering can be challenging
(and this is Google speaking with a
lot of servers and data storage!).
Ok, so how did the authors proceed?
By starting with the beginning,
which is determining the 1,745 languages
the authors would be interested in scraping.
This number is of course an upper bound of what
will come after data gathering and filtering,
since it is too optimistic to
think that for all these languages,
the crawled text would have high enough quality.
The list of 1,745 languages is not
containing 83 languages for which
the authors already have a lot of data.
So, they move on by training a simple and
lightweight language identification model.
It is important for this one to be fast,
because it will look at enormous amounts
of text, at virtually the whole internet.
This model is a CLD3 model which is a feed
forward neural network working on text
represented as a bag of characters,
basically counting how many times
certain character ngrams, so groups
of characters occur in the text.
Maybe you wonder why not bag of words, but
bag of characters? Well, the authors are
working with thousands of languages, where for
a lot of them, it is not straightforward how
to split text into words, since not all
languages are as benevolent as English
where words are separated by spaces (and sentences
are separated by clear punctuation signs).
With character ngrams, the model can be applied
on languages which are harder to tokenize.
They train this model on, we cite
“on an aggregation of proprietary
and publicly available text corpora, with
an average of 800K tokens per language”.
But surprise! The authors did not use this
model to start crawling the dataset just yet,
but just to test on which of the 1,745
languages, the model performs well enough.
Because on some languages, the language
classification error of the language
identifier is just too high, so they drop
these languages, keeping 1,629 of them.
On these 1,629 remaining languages,
they train another CLD3 model.
Why didn’t they use the other CLD3 model
they just trained on 1,745 languages?
We do not know for sure, as the paper is
visibly written by many authors. It looks
like each single one of them did a part in this
pipeline and when writing it up, they sometimes
failed to connect the dots between the different
paper sections to motivate some steps properly.
We can only think of the obvious
reason of retraining another CLD3 model
on just 1,629 languages because
a classification model with less
output possibilities, has a better
chance to not confuse languages.
Ok, great! With this lightweight
language identification model,
the authors finally crawl the internet to
find text in one of these 1,629 languages.
Do you think they are done?
Not so fast! The problems are just starting
because there is a lot of garbage in the
scraped text, like for example random sentences
of non-linguistic content that is fooling the
language identification model into thinking
it’s one of the languages of interest.
So the authors discard sentences
whose language does not correspond
to the language of the whole document.
And they remove the sentences
which do not contain enough
words that are most frequent
for the predicted language.
There is even more filtering going on
here with clustering of languages which
are varieties of the same language and
more filtering based on token frequency.
But there is still some filtering to do. Now
that a raw corpus is already gathered and the
data amounts are bounded, the authors use a more
sophisticated and slower language identification
model to make even better predictions on
what the language of each sentence is.
Yes, you guessed correctly: this more complex
language identifier is transformer-based!
After even more filtering with this
identifier and sentence deduplication,
some languages still needed more
filtering with language-specific fixes.
For example, there were funny occurrences where in
Scottish Gaelic, 570M sentences contained a token
which means download. Or Cree that
had almost only Lorem Ipsum sentences.
And this was it! It was simple enough, right?
No, it wasn't easy at all. The authors let
volunteers (which are native speakers,
but also non-speakers doing detective
work) audit 72 languages to estimate how
much usable data the authors end up with.
The median score is 80%, which speaks a bit for
the difficulty of the problem of scraping the
right data and applying all the right filters
for such a large and diverse set of languages.
Ok, so now that the dataset more or less stands,
the authors are ready to train machine translation
systems on it. But not on all of it, but on that
part of the languages that have enough data,
which is 25,000 sentences before
the deduplication step in filtering.
Yes, you heard right: before the deduplication,
not after. We do not know why, this is again
an unmotivated design choice that
the paper does not care to explain.
So the authors choose 1057 languages which
have 25K sentences before deduplication,
add the 83 high-resource languages they
already had data for to set up an impressive
set of monolingual data. But wait, there
is more, namely the 25 billion sentence
pairs of parallel data of translation
to and from English for 112 languages.
So it’s just now that the machine
translation systems are ready to train.
For the modelling part, there is not really
novelty from this paper (which is nothing bad,
since the main contribution is the dataset and the
engineering work to get models to train on it).
So their modelling choices are pretty
standard: the model learns to translate
the 112 languages with the help of
the parallel data that is available.
But as a second objective, it is
simultaneously trained on the monolingual data,
so on the 1057 + 83 languages with the MASS
training objective, which basically means
that random spans of text are masked out and
the model needs to predict the MASKed tokens.
It is like BERT, but instead of masking individual
tokens, here we mask entire groups of words.
The idea of this simultaneous training
on parallel and monolingual data is that
the parallel data teaches the model to
translate between around a 100 languages,
the masked language modelling
on monolingual data teaches the
model something useful about language in general.
Such that at the end of training, the model is
able to do not only translate between
the 100 languages with parallel data,
but also do rough translations between
English and the rest of the languages.
Which comes in handy, because now the authors
use another established technique in machine
translation, called self training via
back translation. Meaning that the model
can continue training in a second stage
by using the two objectives we know so
far – translation and masked language modelling
at span level – but also train to translate on
sentence translation pairs that previous
checkpoints of the model have generated.
So here we are, with trained models
on more than a thousand languages.
There are quite a number of ablations the authors
do, but we will focus on two kinds of experiments:
the first experiment is comparing a
1.5 Billion and a 6 Billion parameter
model trained on a combination of 112
languages with parallel data and 206
languages with monolingual data. So we
are not yet at a 1000 languages here.
Unsurprisingly, the more parameters models
have, the better they memorize / ahm, we mean
capture the diversity of all these languages, at
least when it comes to translating into English.
But the most interesting part was when
the authors compared a model trained on
200 languages with one trained on 1000
languages: What would we expect here?
Well, of course the model trained with 1000
languages can translate between more languages!
Duh! But the surprising part is that
adding so many as a thousand languages
from which most are low-resource
and noisier in quality, does not
interfere with the translation performance
of most high resource languages. This is a
bit unexpected because previous work by Siddhant
and collaborators made us think that adding many
low resource languages in the dataset of
monolingual sentences, can hurt model performance.
The explanation of the authors is not necessarily
proven or exact, but they hypothesized
that after a certain number of languages,
the probability for each added language to
be similar to an already existing one, increases.
In other words, it might seem complex to translate
between a thousand languages, if they do
not have any similarities. But they do,
which explains the observed effect. Unfortunately,
this paper does not have a full suite of
experiments that gradually increases the number
of languages from the hundreds to the thousands
to see at what language number this effect
starts to appear and whether the improvement
is continuous or makes a discontinuous jump.
Now thinking a bit further about this,
what would be interesting to know
in this highly multilingual regime,
is whether languages with a lot of resources
that were seen more often by the model, somehow
affect or culturally imprint the low resource
languages. More concretely, we are wondering
whether a multilingual model that has seen a lot
of English but not so much Romanian would “think”
more in English than in “Romanian”, introducing
English specificities in Romanian translations.
But now it’s time to conclude this video by
noting that the contributions of this paper
are great! The thing to be unhappy about
is that the release of this paper does
not come with a release of the data or
of the models. We guess that Google has
little incentive to open source the research
they base their Google Translate product on.
Speaking of open source, look at Meta’s
response to this paper: They train a 200
language machine translation system and open
source it! I guess Google wins at the number
of languages, but Meta AI wins at making its
research more accessible to a wider public.
So what are your thoughts on
this? Let us know in the comments.
We hope you learned something today
and hope to see you in a next video!
Okay, bye!